Varsovie a décidé encore de bloquer le
blé ukrainien décision unilatérale du
gouvernement polonais sur l'interdiction
d'importer des céréales ukrainiennes à
un mois des élections législatives
l'opposition démocratique se présentera
une nouvelle fois en ordre dispersé
Mariam pierzad la Pologne a soutenu
massivement l'Ukraine et a accueilli
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
réfugiés mais elle a décidé de protéger
son agriculture oui il y a deux raisons
à cela d'abord elle est la première
raison elle l' électorale 40 % des
populations de la population polonaise
vit dans des zones rurales c'est un des
plus haut taux de l'Union européenne
pourquoi parce que l'électorat du pis le
parti au pouvoir se trouve en partie sur
ces zones rural dans les petites villes
dans les villages qui sont donc touchés
de plein fouet hein par cette
problématique des céréales ukrainiennes
les agriculteurs polonais qui vote
d'ailleurs en partie pour le parti au
pouvoir il pointaiit du doigt C cette
importation de cérales ukrainiennes et
il mettait en avant la baisse du prix
sur le le marché de leur propre céréales
mais ils accusent également le lait ou
la vient d'avoir subi une d'avoir baissé
à cause des importations ukrainiennes et
que l'arrivée finalement de ces produits
Ukrainiens sur le marché polonais et
bien on voit bien que c'est très
sensible dans le pays d'autant que les
produits Ukrainiens sont complètement
exemptés de droits de douane dans
l'Union européenne depuis le 24 février
2022 et l'invasion russe en Ukraine donc
pour le pis le parti au pouvoir il ne
faut surtout pas perdre cette base
électorale rurale importante on est à un
mois pile hein des élections et
finalement l'interdiction de de cette
qui qui arrête qui s'arrête aujourd'hui
est devenu l'un des principaux arguments
de campagne du pis la seconde elle est
idéologique c'est une nouvelle façon
aussi de s'opposer à Bruxelles puisquen
avril l'Europe avait autorisé à
contre-cœur cinq pays dont la Pologne a
interdir la commercialisation des
séréales Ukrainiens et donc ce décret
prend fin aujourd'hui le PCE parti ultra
conservateur rappelons-le nous sommes à
un mois des élections législatives et on
dit que ce scrutin sera le plus
important depuis 1989 exactement car
cela va être en fait un choix entre deux
Polognes de vision de la Pologne d'abord
entre le parti au pouvoir le pis le
parti Droit et Justice vous l'avez dit
un parti ultra conservateur représenté
par jaroslo kashinski qui dirige ce
parti face à lui il y aura Donald Tusk
qu'on connaît plus ici en en Europe
puisqu'il a été président du Conseil EUR
européen de 2014 à 2019 il a aussi
dirigé la Pologne de 2007 à 2014 donc
deux visions de la Pologne totalement
opposée le pis qui est au pouvoir depuis
8 ans on va le voir euh quel est le
bilan euh c'est finalement un recul de
la démocratie de grandes manifestations
on se rappelle de ces grandes
manifestations en juin dernier contre ce
recul de la démocratie 8 ans de pouvoir
c'est quoi c'est un recul sur les droits
des femmes avec un un IVG qui est
quasiment interdit en Pologne un recul
sur les droits LGBT une perte
d'indépendance pour la justice une
liberté de la presse écornée puisque
maintenant le pouvoir a la possibilité
de nommer et de défaire les dirigeants
de l'audiovisuel public en Pologne et
donc face à cette politique il y a
Donald Tusk qui promet une Pologne
ouverte sur le monde un retour sur les
droits qui ont reculé ces dernières
années ces élections législatives dans
un mois donc jour pour jour elles vont
être très importantes même essentielles
pour la démocratie dans le pays une
démocratie donc on a vu qui recule sans
cesse et qui est régulièrement rappelé à
l'ordre par Bruxelles avec qui les
relations sont extrêmement tendues ça
aura également des incidenceces euh en
Europe puisque de là dépend
effectivement la relation entre la
Pologne très important an vous l'avez
dit depuis l'invasion russe en Ukraine
qui aide fortement militairement
l'Ukraine et qui a accueilli dans son
pays également beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
merci beaucoup Mariam pierzad pour votre
analyse merci à vous